[Music]
all right all right which of course he
did but you know there's a lot of that
going around ain't there honestly into the
exact second I thought you were build-a-bear
maybe I am where would we go once this
plan was complete his answer was always
the same to the car that's cute dennis has
a retirement plan let's go get this son of
a [__] language I am inevitable
what did you do that for the head
Carol are we seeing you here next month not
likely what you gonna get another haircut
listen for a face why are you bullying me these
few ships cleaner water you know if you're about
to tell me to look on the bright side um I'm
about to hit you in the head with a peanut
butter sandwich it's fine actually my never
wears anything I'm wired these are confusing
times right no no that's not what I meant I'm
not I'm kidding you want to grab one with me
I'm ant-man your whole face wait they don't know
nobody nobody to know he was I knew I had to take
a picture with you look he's even saying no he
doesn't I get along the kid on anybody but you
I don't want a picture with he's gonna feel bad
sorry Bruce yeah Bruce listen your mom [__]
language why are you up cuz I got some important
[__] going on here what do you think go to bed
I'll sell all your toys night I have no idea
MA we're talking about time travel here either
it's all a joke or none of it is we're good you
tell me Dad it's baby it's Scott as a baby no
grow bring Scott back somebody peed my pants
oh thank you but I don't know if it was baby
me or old me or just me me i I see this is an
absolute wind Tony I don't know you made it
for you plus honestly I have to get out of
the garage before Morgan takes it sledding
oh my god oh my god it's so good to see
you give me your cuddly little rascal
Master in noob Master 69 new master hey
it's for again you know the god of thunder
listen buddy if you don't log off this
game immediately I'm gonna fly over to
your house come down to that basement you're
hiding in rip off your arms and shove them
up your butt let's go cry to your father
you little weasels goodbye I need you pal
there's beer on the ship see ya negro
that's all you had to say don't give me
I'm sorry I couldn't give it to you sooner
plus two test runs one test run breath and
nothing nebula impossible Thor what
do you know I've mastered the ability
standing is so incredibly still could I
become invisible to the eye is he asleep
no no I'm pretty sure he's dead from the
Dark Elves scary being so Jane actually
[Music] maybe smashed a few things along the
way I think it's gratuitous but whatever that
suit did nothing for your ass no one asked you
to look don't you think I think you look great
cap as far as I'm concerned that's America's
ass buddy what do you think maximum occupancy
has been reached the stud yes stop stop I'm
gonna do what's called a pro-gamer move [Music]
is that Axe body spray yeah I had a can of
the different merchants each relax can we
focus please I'm going inside you now medic medic
you got some help yourself jack I can do this all
day have you do this all day I can do this all
day yeah I know I know that is America's I'm
sorry this is the part where you know spikes
come out with skeletons on the end of them and
everything what are you talking when you break
into a place called the Temple of the Power
Stone there's gonna be a bunch of booby traps
okay go ahead you're in no condition we'll do
what do you think is coursing through my
veins right now cheese whiz just like I
was made for this you could not live with
your own failure where did that bring you
not tonight not necessary there should
be no knifing one another everybody
knows it was in charge me look at
me short under captain now please
like the video and subscribe
no well I don't think I will